all of our social media Jen Aiden threw
a drink at Joe Gorga yes
[Music]
[Applause]
when you see things getting to that
place what runs through your head I
think it's gross period end of story
yeah period dot yes period dot
Louis you may now kiss your gorgeous
Pride
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
are we ready for Jersey yeah Jersey is
excellent and we've got some new blood
it feels like the Jersey we love and
obviously there's you know some major
shifts in the Teresa Melissa Joe Gorga
relationship but we've got some some new
women in the mix who really energized
the show but they feel perfectly Jersey
and they fit in the group really well
it's been very mixed between the judices
and the gorgas and the rules now this
weekend of like where this thing goes
from here do you have any idea where it
can go from here
I don't think it's gonna going anywhere
good anytime soon unfortunately would it
be like one of them is no longer a
housewife territory oh where that's
going oh well that's I mean that's a
conversation for like a year from now
right we gotta get through the seasons
we have a full season ready to go we
have a reunion we haven't done I mean a
lot can happen
foreign